the spat continues between President
Trump and some members of the squad
after Israel banned reps ilhan Omar and
Rasheeda to lead from entering the
country over their support of a boycott
movement President Trump publicly
blasting those radical Dems and
supporting the ban
well I'm only involved from the
standpoint of they are very anti-jewish
and they're very anti-israel I think
it's disgraceful the things they've said
you have lists of that this isn't just a
one line mistake what they've said about
Israel and Jewish people is a horrible
thing and they become the face of the
Democrat Party Israel did reverse course
after congressman Talib asked to visit
her family there on humanitarian grounds
to leave then rejected the offer
claiming Israel is trying to silence her
and is treating her like a criminal
I find her decision personally
deplorable and also I don't understand
it as a granddaughter - I would give
anything to spend one minute with all of
my deceased grandparents I don't know
why there's some type of stance that she
would take now when says it's a stunt it
is because she hasn't said anything
about the wee girls in the China
concentration camp she hasn't said
anything about my amar and they're
working this so if she's so concerned
about the oppression of Muslims around
the world and if she's so concerned
about us trying to silence her yet how
is it that she's using the position of a
congressman here and she can legislate
which seems to be a louder position than
any of us have she wrote a letter saying
she dearly needed to see her very old
grandmother and Israel approved and then
she said ah you know what I'm not gonna
do it so she used her elderly
grandmother as a prop for a stunt and
let's not forget that the trip that she
was planning on going was put together
or planned with an anti-semitic group so
common sense is if someone's going to
your house which specifically to
vandalize it or destroy it you shouldn't
have them there and then she used her
grandmother as a Trojan horse to get in
it's all it's disgusting I'll tell you
what's disgusting is President Trump
President Trump going to a foreign
country in saying that a member of our
Congress the American Congress duly
elected can't travel to your country and
our president
working against the US government I
don't think it happened exactly he's on
there pressuring Netanyahu making a
political deal drawing in politics
because he wants to make these four
somehow the face of the Democratic Party
we are the Democratic Party the House
Majority clearly voted against a
supporter boycott and divestment issues
in Israel the Democrats are strong
supporters of Israel most Jewish people
vote Democratic not only that you have
more several leading Republicans saying
this was a mistake mr. president the
reaction has been so substantiating use
your grandmother many corners and you
guys somehow wanted to make let me tell
you she's posturing that would agree
this is a reaction to the fact that
president she planned it before acting
in such an obnoxious and rude and
political manner the obnoxious is all
the squad you know what this reminds me
of when Pelosi tried to fly overseas
during the shutdown negotiate this deal
this is what happened he pulled the rug
out from under her because they were
going on a fact-finding mission or
diplomatic mission they were going to
cause trouble and bivy said I'll save us
all the trouble and goodbye and you're
right the group that sponsored them is
almost a hate group if your research
hasn't been reported but notice who
didn't go on the trip
AOC mm-hmm I wonder why because Nancy
when she had the one-on-one with AOC
after that whole kerfuffle she probably
said you know you're a real rising star
smart now if you need to separate
yourself from the rest of those people
because they're not doing you any good
okay so support for Israel used to be a
bipartisan thing right and just two
weeks ago or them within the last week I
think 51 members of Congress Republicans
and Democrats went together with AIPAC
and they went all together these two
decided not to go with them they could
have gone on that trip and decided not
to so this was a separate thing meant to
separate and now I so there's the Trump
part and people can look at the trump
card they can argue about it but again
what happened with President Trump is
he's not afraid about the blowback you
care raised like I don't care he's like
but now what is happening we're actually
talking about the specific issue I'm
out the position that they take on
Israel on the BDS movement on that and
so he doesn't like going after President
Trump on this is futile if you're the
Democrats you're gonna have to start
answering do you agree with that do you
agree with them do you agree there and
they're all gonna be asked every single
time and I still cannot think of a
single day since January 1st when the
Democrats have actually been on offense
on a single media news cycle it going
into an election year with the president
that said about the 43 percent approval
rating and they still can't do it that's
stunning